der etat des familienministeriums
soll umfassen nach jetzigen stand nach
entwurf stand des haushalts 12,9
milliarden euro das sind 280 millionen
mehr als in diesem jahr und der
ministerin auch schon am pult und wird
über schwerpunkte ihres ministeriums
berichten
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen sehr
geehrte gäste sehr geehrte zuschauende
jeder und jedem von ihnen fällt sofort
ein beispiel ein wie die aktuellen
krisen ihren persönlichen alltag
finanziell belasten die teuer kartoffeln
brot strom energie und als recht urlaub
geworden sind
wir sehen dass wir tun was dagegen wir
lassen niemanden in schwierigen zeiten
allein meine damen und herren
wohl dem der nicht jeden cent der nicht
auf jeden cent achten muss oder eine
eigene vorstellung davon hat mit den
steigenden kosten umzugehen das
bundesministerium für familie senioren
familie und jugend hat aber die im blick
die das nicht können die eltern die
alleinerziehenden die schon vor corinna
eisern gehaushaltet und alles für ihre
kinder getan haben damit sie ihnen
buntstifte ordentliche schuhe ein
gesundes essen bieten können die
senioren die weiterhin selbstbestimmt
leben und am gesellschaftlichen leben
teilhaben wollen die jugendlichen den iq
wie in der korona krise auch so vieles
verzichtet haben die aber eine gute
zukunft verdienen und so wichtig sind
für unsere gesellschaft und für eine
nachhaltige transformation unseres
handelns und unseres wirtschaftens die
frauen die in allen krisen den laden
zusammen und am laufen halten in der
gesellschaft in den familien und immer
wieder schlechter bezahlt sind als
männer oder eben auch gar nicht bezahlt
werden für ihre arbeit für kinder und
für ihre angehörigen
dieser fokus prägt den haushalt 23
meines ministeriums
wir entlastend in der krise und wir
investieren in die zukunft meine damen
und herren
der haushaltsentwurf sieht einen etat
von rund 12,9 milliarden euro vor die
wir für familien und gesellschaftlich zu
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
einsetzen werden für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit also an erster stelle
steht kinderarmut zu bekämpfen darum die
kindergrundsicherung
sie wird einkommensschwachen familien
sie wird einkommensschwache familien
unterstützen weil es neben dem
garantiebetrag einen
einkommensabhängigen zusatzbeitrag geben
wird und wie werden sie so einfach auf
gestalten dass sie wirklich alle kinder
erreicht auch unabhängig vom
familienmodell ihrer eltern
so legen wir kinderarmut so kommen wie
sozialer chancengerechtigkeit endlich
ein großes stück näher bis das 2025 so
weit ist werden die kinder die mit hartz
iv auskommen müssen oder wohngeld
bekommen einen sofort zuschlag bekommen
von 20 euro pro monat das sind für 2023
insgesamt rund 1,5 milliarden euro mit
dem entlastungspaket gehen wir aber noch
einen schritt weiter und erhöhen das
kindergeld um 18 euro pro monat das
entlaste familien gezielt von den kosten
der inflation denn sie trifft die
inflation ganz besonders
und wir erhöhen auch für kinder im
hartz-iv-bezug mit dem bürgergeld die
regelsätze damit die ärmsten kindern
besser geschützt sind vor ort
und das sind alles weitere wichtige
schritte hin zu kindergrundsicherung
liebe abgeordnete liebe zu schauen die
kinder lernen früh sie lernt schnell und
sie lernen gründlich und am besten
fördern wir sie durch eine gute
frühkindliche bildung in den kitas und
zwar überall in deutschland
und der zeit lassen
peter qualität gesetzt und bevor hier
irgendjemand behauptet wir schafften die
sprach geht das ab räume ich mit dem
irrtum auf wir nehmen in den nächsten
zwei jahren vier milliarden euro in die
hand und investieren ganz gezielt in die
qualität der kindertagesbetreuung und
das heißt konkret in qualifiziertes
fachpersonal in gute ausstattung in
gesundheit ernährung bewegung und das
heißt vorrangig in die sprachliche
bildung
und die länder haben es nun in der hand
die förderung der sprachlichen bildung
mit hilfe der bundesmittel zu
verstetigen wir brauchen eben die
regelfinanzierung der sprachförderung
und nicht weiter irgendwelche
modellprojekte wir legen das erste wir
stellen das geld zur verfügung aber tun
müssen die länder mit uns gemeinsam hat
und
das ist auch ganz wichtig weil wir
brauchen in deutschland gemeinsame und
breite qualitätsstandards in den kitas
und doch daran werden wir weiter
arbeiten
damit kinder hoch qualifiziert betreut
werden egal wo sie leben auch das ist
unsere investition in die zukunft
ich war vor zwei wochen in sachsen
anhalt in teutschenthal wo jugendliche
mit mitteln des krone auf und pakets von
mai bis august ein selbst geplantes
sport und freizeitgelände einen
jugendtreff und einen digitalen
infokanal aus dem boden gestampft haben
und das in vier monaten das geht meine
damen und herren
sie sind jetzt stolze wolle
und das war es ihr projekt ist sie haben
es geplant sie haben es durchgeführt und
sie werden es jetzt pflegen und das
macht sie stark meine damen und herren
genau da werden wir mit dem
zukunftspaket für bewegung kultur und
gesundheit einsetzen 50 millionen euro
für projekte von jugendlichen und
kindern zum ausgleich und zum nachholen
nachdem ganzen verzicht der korona
monate das passt zu unserem engagement
im rahmen von demokratie leben wir
stärken junge menschen und wir stärken
demokratie indem wir all jene
unterstützen die sich unsere demokratie
einsetzen 200 millionen euro stellen wir
insgesamt dafür zur verfügung noch
einmal 16,5 millionen mehr als im
vergangenen jahr und diese
bundesregierung wird noch in diesem jahr
den ersten aktionsplan gegen trier
feindlichkeit beschließen wie bitter
nötig das ist das zeigt der mörderisch
homophobe hass dem wald zum opfer fiel
ein 25-jähriger trans mann wurde
erschlagen als er beim csd stellte fest
in münster eine lesbische frau vor
attacken schützen wollte das geht uns
alle an er liebe tae kyu menschen
brauchen unseren schutz und wir werden
mit dem nationalen aktionsplan den
rahmen dafür geben
hätte abgeordnete werde zuschauen es
geht um die innere stärke unserer
gesellschaft um das zusammenhalten
besonders in krisenzeiten wie diesen ich
bin überzeugt sie die bürgerinnen und
bürger sie sehen dass sie wollen dass
sie verstehen dass wir in krisenzeiten
zusammenhalten müssen und dass wir diese
krise gemeinsam bewältigen können und
zwar solidarisch sie registrieren auch
auf der anderen seite die rechte und die
demokratie feinde aus der krise krise
aber profit schlagen wollen und
behaupten die da oben in den regierungen
von bund und ländern die machten was sie
wollen und nehmen den normalen menschen
was weg meine damen und herren das wird
nicht wahrer nur weil es immer lauter
gebrüllt wird die folgen von krieg und
klimakrise ja die strapazieren die
nerven und sie strapazieren die
geldbörsen aber wir können diese
aufgaben lösen wenn wir es zusammen tun
deshalb bitte ich sie
wehrte ab konnte aus den demokratischen
fraktionen um ihre unterstützung
die lisa paus die ministerin für familie
senioren frauen und jugend hat dem ihren
beitrag einen schwerpunkt auf kinder
gesetz deren förderung etwa sprachlichen
bildung und auf finanzielle sicherheit
und das ganze natürlich vor dem
hintergrund der korona pandemie und den
dadurch erlittenen
defiziten für die unions fraktion sylvia
brack familienpolitische sprecherin
[Musik]
für das bmj was sie hier vorliegen und
ihr haushalt wächst das ist auch gut und
richtig und wichtig so es wächst aber
vor allen dingen auch durch die
gesetzlichen leistungen gesetzliche
ansprüche die bestehen und sie selber
verweisen darauf aufs kindergeld das
erbe angehoben wird das kindergeld ist
bis auf ganz wenige ausnahmen überhaupt
nicht in ihrem haushalt verankert aber
wenn sie schon darauf hinweisen dass sie
18 euro für jedes kind darauf geben
wollen dann würde ich sagen vielleicht
sprechen wir auch mal über das dritte
kind über das vierte kind und über das
fünfte kind für die nicht dieser 18 euro
nicht gibt sondern es gibt sie nur für
die ersten und zweiten mehrkindfamilien
in diesem land gehen hier leider leer
aus in ihrem haushalt sollte allerdings
einfach noch viel mehr stecken denn es
ist das familienministerium und die
herausforderungen sind riesig und sie
frau ministerin haben in ihrer ersten
rede in der april gesagt wie wichtig ihm
chancengleichheit für kinder ist ein
zitat von ihnen aus der rede ich finde
mich nicht damit ab dass menschen mit
ihren talenten und fähigkeiten auf der
strecke bleiben nur weil sie
benachteiligt sind ich finde es wirklich
schade dass genau hier sie die
unterstützung ihrer koalition scheinbar
nicht haben denn in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag hatten sie noch was
ganz anderes
verabredet und genau daran wollen wir
sie messen ihr haushalt versagt gerade
im bereich frühkindlicher bildung gerade
wenn es um chancengleichheit geht völlig
sie haben im koalitionsvertrag
versprochen ich zitiere das
bundesprogramm sprach kita wollen wir
weiter entwickle und verstetigen der
stetigen ausrufezeichen ihre politik sie
streichen dieses bundesprogramm sprach
kita dieses programm gibt es jetzt im
zwölften jahr es ist bundesweit
erfolgreich mit über
7.500 fachkräften die gerade die
benachteiligten die schwächeren kinder
beim spracherwerb unterstützen es sind
netzwerke entstanden erzieherinnen und
erzieher werden weitergebildet die
einrichtungen weiterentwickelt sprache
ist die grundlage für alles sprache ist
die grundlage für chancen von kindern
egal ob sie benachteiligt sind oder
nicht und genau das beenden sie ihre
staatssekretärin hatte unsere frage
gesagt wir übergeben die entstandenen
und erprobten strukturen und ansätze in
die verwandt waren in die verantwortung
der länder nein sie zerstören diese
strukturen sie verweisen auf das
qualitäts gesetz was da kommen mag aber
wir haben schon jetzt eine gute kita
gesetzt schon jetzt sind zwei milliarden
pro jahr sie erhöhen diese mittel gerade
nicht für die sprach- kita gab es im
vergangenen in den vergangenen jahren in
diesem jahr 248 millionen diese mittel
stellen sie den ländern nicht zusätzlich
zur verfügung und es gibt keine
absprache mit den ländern keine
verabredungen wie das denn bitte zum 1 1
23 umgesetzt werden sollen laut ihrem
haushalt gibt es am 11 keine 7500
fachkräfte mehr der finanzminister sagt
dazu es wird keine verschlechterungen in
den einrichtungen geben sagen sie das
mal den leiter der einrichtung deren
mitarbeiter jetzt schon gekündigt haben
weil sie im ersten ersten keinen vertrag
mehr haben sagen sie das den leiter in
dieser einrichtung wo die fachkräfte
nicht wissen was am ersten ersten
passiert die die kinder jeden tag in
ihrer kita haben die hilfe brauchen die
genau die sprachförderung brauchen und
das können sie mit den mitarbeitenden
die sie jetzt haben einfach nicht
leisten der kollege von malottki sagt
dazu von der spd der finanz minister
tesch fachkräfte und eltern das
bundesland mecklenburg vorpommern spd
regiert kündigte bundesratsinitiative
dazu auf dazu an hören sie endlich auf
zu streiten halten sie sich einfach nur
an ihre eigenen zusagen aus dem
koalitionsvertrag und setzen sie das
programm vor
die streifen nämlich nicht nur dieses
programm die fachkräfte offensive
erzieherinnen und erzieher eingestellt
zugesagt im chor vertrag ein
investitionsprogramm zum weiteren ausbau
von kitaplätzen gibt es in ihrem
haushalt nicht die frühen hilfen wollten
sie laut koalitionsvertrag dynamisieren
was auch immer das heißt das programm
schritt zurück auf vor drei jahren
zurück volumen nur noch 51 millionen
euro kann ich mal mehr der
inflationsausgleich nicht mal die die
lohn mehrkosten sind drin und im
anschluss haben sie da möchten sie ich
unterbreche sie war die redezeit fast zu
ende und fragen sie ob sie eine
zwischenfrage von einem trickbetrüger
sind danke gut
das sind alles nur versprechen aus ihrem
eigenen koalitionsvertrag und diese
halten sie nicht an wir und nicht nur
wir sondern auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger die kinder und familien in diesem
land halten sie einfach nur an ihre
eigenen zusagen an ihrer aus ihrer
sogenannten zukunfts koalition für die
zukunft der schwächeren der kinder in
diesem land ist da leider nicht viel
drin und wir werden da erhebliche
nachbesserungen einfordern und freuen
uns auf die beratungen vielen dank
sylvia bauer aus der unionsfraktion und
die und das zeigt auch dieser beitrag
hier gibt sich in der opposition
deutlich freigebig aber sozialleistungen
angeht als das zu regierungszeiten der
fall war jetzt eine zwischenfrage von
otto fricke aus der fdp fraktion
sie haben jetzt ganz viele vorschläge
gemacht was man alles was diese
koalition noch alles an dingen
verlängern müsse die sie als cdu die sie
abgewählt worden sind aus der regierung
machen würden anstatt anstatt an anstatt
anstatt der koalition und der ministerin
die möglichkeit zu geben das was in der
koalitionsvereinbarung steht so
umzusetzen wie diese koalition ist
fürchtet aber dennoch frage ich sie
nachdem was die sind jetzt alle weg nach
dem schuldigen stimmt nicht bis auf den
landesgruppenvorsitzende der einstmals
stolzen csu nach dem was ihre vorgänger
in der rede zum finanzplan zur finanz
und haushaltspolitik gesagt haben frage
ich sie jetzt werden sie all das was sie
kritisiert haben wo das geld fehlt und
wo sie der meinung sind der bund müsste
das wieder für die länder machen wird
die cdu/csu und diese anträge im
haushaltsverfahren stellen mit welchem
wert oder ist das hier nur heiße luft
frau brier zur antwort
vielen dank herr kollege wenn sie mir
zugehört haben dann haben sie sehr wohl
mitbekommen dass ich gesagt habe ich
messe sie an ihren eigenen versprechen
da ich habe sie zitiert aus ihren
koalitionsvertrag und ich habe die
ministerin zitiert aus ihrer eigenen
regeln und zum thema sprach peter ja
wird es von uns einen entsprechenden
antrag und einen finanzierungsvorschlag
geben und so habe ich mich bislang auch
jedesmal eingelassen vielen dank
nächsten kleines zwischenspiel überall
dazwischen silvia breher und otto fricke
und auf dem weg zum pult ist sönke rix
spd-fraktion dort stellvertretender
vorsitzender verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen wir haben ja zusammen in den
hallen wir wir haben ja zusammen in den
vergangenen
vergangenen jahren regiert und es war
auch nicht alles schlecht muss man auch
dazu sagen jetzt ist es vieles
allerdings wird es vieles allerdings
besser und ich will
und ich will da ganz kurz noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass wir immer
gemeinsam der auffassung waren da wo die
länder originär die zuständigkeit haben
unterstützen wir sie gerne aber wir
wollen dass sie ihre originären
zuständigkeiten auch wahrnehmen ihre
aufgaben auch wahrnehmen und
weiß es ganz genau nadine schön und
marcus weinberg haben das immer wieder
betont das war übrigens auch der grund
warum die union gar nicht auf die idee
gekommen wäre eine gute kita gesetz auf
den weg zu bringen das haben wir als
sozialdemokraten damals in den
koalitionsvertrag gebracht das war nicht
ihre idee die union war eigentlich
damals dagegen ein bundesweites
qualifikations qualifizierungs gesetze
auf einmal entdecken sie in der
opposition auf einmal entdecken sie in
der opposition ihre zuneigung zur kita
ist ja schön ist ja gut ist ja wunderbar
entdecken sie die bitte aber auch in den
ländern in denen sie verantwortung
tragen liebe kolleginnen
brave sprache es grund sprache ist ist
die sprache ist die grundlage für alles
haben sie gerade eben gesagt und wenn
man den koalitionsvertrag genau liest
dann steht da wir wollen das programm
oder beziehungsweise freuen die qualität
die sprache geht dass die
sprachförderung verstetigen was bedeutet
das für ein gesetzgeber verstetigen es
ein gesetz überführen und kein programm
und keine projekte macht das sind die
grundlagen so verstetigen wir als
bundesgesetzgeber und wir überführen ist
in ein gesetz und zwar ins qualitäts
gesetz und das ist auch richtig so aber
wie wird kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wissen schon es gibt jetzt hier
strukturen vor ort da müssen wir jetzt
bei den haushaltsberatungen noch mal
darauf achten dass wir die auch nutzen
damit sie erfolgreich ins qualitäts
gesetz überführt werden können aber so
ist es bei haushalten da gucken wir noch
einmal als haushaltsgesetzgeber drauf
und versuchen diese strukturen da eine
übergangslösung zu finden wie hat
sozialdemokraten auf jeden fall wären
dazu bereit
ich habe zwei familien getroffen in den
letzten wochen wir waren alle unterwegs
eine erzählte mir sie hatten ein
baugrundstück bei mir in der genfer sich
gekauft und das mussten sie zurückgeben
weil die preise so massiv gestiegen sind
eine andere familie erzählte mir sie
wollen auf den nachmittagsbetreuung
verzichten ihres kindes wally sie zu
teuer ist weil sie sich aufgrund der
preissteigerung lieber erstmal die
lebensmittel und die haushalt und das
haus usw
finanzieren müssen das sind dramatische
situationen die angekommen sind bei
familien bei denen wir eigentlich
gedacht haben sie sind auf dem er auf
der ebene dass sie gar nicht für
staatliche unterstützung brauchen aber
sie brauchen gerade in der zeit jetzt wo
die energiepreise und allgemein die
preissteigerung sehr stabil sind sie
brauchen diese unterstützung und es ist
gut dass wir im letzten maßnahmen paket
und das ist das dritte maßnahmenpaket
was jetzt die koalition auf den weg
gebracht hat gerade diese familien auch
in den blick in dem liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
nicht nur durch die erhöhung des
bürgergeldes auf 500 euro die ausweitung
des wohngeldes die einführung einer
strompreis bremse die erhöhung des
kindergeldes und erhöhung des
kinderzuschlages unterstützen wir nein
wir unterstützen natürlich auch weiter
denn wir haben einerseits die aufgabe
ins system einzugreifen beispielsweise
über die strom bremse aber andererseits
auch die aufgabe dauerhaft für
entlastung unterstützung zu sorgen und
deshalb wird diese koalition auch die
kindergrundsicherung einführen nach den
hilfspaketen kommt auch die dauerhafte
lösung und das ist die
kindergrundsicherung diese probleme
denn im gegensatz zu dem was im moment
bei der union vorgetragen wird sind wir
schon länger dafür auch familien
dauerhaft zu entlasten und entdeckten
nicht plötzlich erst die zuneigung für
kitas und familien wenn wir in der
opposition angekommen sind dafür
arbeitet diese koalition herzlichen dank
die regenrinnen für die ard ist marianne
rate kühne
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren der naive hat geglaubt dass die
fdp in der ampel als korrektiv linker
politik wirken könnte der realist wusste
dass es anders kommt und der vorliegende
haushalts land gibt dem realisten recht
linke und pseudoliberale sind letztlich
zwei seiten derselben medaille
die vielen fdp wähler die das anderssein
kommen sich jetzt betrogen vor
sanktionen gegen russland bald
sanktionen gegen china eine
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte die
deutsche als kartoffel geschimpft wird
ein selbstbestimmung das gesetz mit dem
bereits jugendliche im jahrestakt ihr
geschlecht wechseln können dieser
wahnsinn ist auch made by fdp aber
christian lindner soll im welt
-interview die fdp verhindere einen
linksruck hofer braucht man die fdp
überhaupt noch gar nicht und die
politische linke wiederum hat die
menschen aufgegeben die früher in ihrem
fokus standen arbeiter sozial bedürftige
rentner familien werden sie sich nun
vorrangig sexuellen ethischen oder
sonstigen minderheiten wird mit einblick
in den vorliegenden familien
haushaltsplan macht diese falsche
prioritätensetzung besonders deutlich
die mittel für die bundesstiftung
gleichstellung sollen um zwei drittel
erhöht werden und auch generell werden
mehr mittel für gleichstellungspolitik
veranschlagt lassen sie doch einfach
frauen frauen und männer männer seien
statt sie ständig in ein gleichstellungs
corsa zu zwingen schluss mit diesen
politischen geschlechtsumwandlung und
besonders dreist ich die erhöhung der
mittel für die förderung der maßnahmen
zur stärkung von demokratie und vielfalt
was blutig klingt ist nichts anderes als
linke kader subventionierung und die ist
auch noch wirklich bemessen ist 140
millionen euro sind für diesen
haushaltsposten vorgesehen das sind 33
millionen euro mehr als im vorjahr und
fast doppelt so viel wie
2020 das freut natürlich ex stasi
mitarbeiterin kahane tier als
spielstätten der antonio amadeus
stiftung mal wieder zu den begünstigten
zählen wird sie hat erklärt die größte
bankrotterklärung der deutschen politik
nach der wende sei es gewesen dass sie
zugelassen habe dass ein drittel des
staatsgebiets weiß blieb deutschland im
jahr 2022 das ist ein ehemaliger stasi
funktionäre und staatlich subventioniert
in fragen der demokratie und vielfalt
belehren wollen
und was sie einen gekommen mit den
anderen eben genommen die mittel für die
förderung des ehrenamtes werden mal eben
um zwei drittel gestrichen die mittel
zur unterstützung gewalt betroffene
frauen mit kindern werden nicht erhöht
das wäre bitter nötig denn die
frauenhäuser platzen dank ihrer
migrationspolitik aus allen nähten und
die zuschüsse für aufgaben der politik
für ältere menschen und den
demografischen wandel werden um etwa
drei millionen euro gekürzt dabei ist
die demokratische entwicklung unseres
landes eine katastrophe
die geburtenrate liegt deutlich
unterhalb des bestands erhaltenen
niveaus seit 50 jahren sterben mehr
menschen in deutschland als geboren
werden ihre tricks die politische
aufgabe wäre also diese demografische
katastrophe abzuwenden zum beispiel
indem man familien steuerlich entlastet
oder das familiensplitting einführt die
mehrwertsteuer auf artikel des
kinderbedarf senkt eine kultur des
lebens förder die hilfen für schwangere
und ungewollt kinderlose ausbaut etc das
wäre mal politik für das eigene volk
aber was machen sie gerade drei prozent
des gesamthaushaltes sind für den
familien haushalt eingeplant 600 euro
weniger als zuvor und dafür sind noch
große teile für links ideologisch
projekt und natürlich wie ihre eigene
partei jugend vorgesehen mitten in einer
von ihrer politik herbeigeführten
energie und wirtschaftskrise in der
familien jeden cent brauchen könnten
aber sie sie beschwören eine abtreibung
school sie greifen die traditionelle
familien und die demokratische
entwicklung dient ihnen als vorwand für
offene grenzen und für noch mehr
migration und nein da dramatisiere ich
nichts ein landtagsabgeordnete der
grünen immerhin regierungspartei fordert
ja ganz offen zuwanderung bis zum
volkssturm mit zuwanderung bis zum
volkstod kann man vielleicht aus linker
sicht die demografische krise lösen aber
man schafft so 1000 neue probleme fassen
wir also zusammen
wir sollen flagge zeigen aber nicht die
schwarz-rot-goldene sondern am besten
die regen beruf haben wir sollen 67
geschlechter akzeptieren aber unser
eigenes in frage stellen wir sollten
alles fremde lieben aber das eigene
nicht wir sollen vielen gegen putin kalt
duschen fürs klima den gürtel enger
schnallen während der deutsche staat
noch mehr geld für linke kader
subventionierung politische
geschlechtsumwandlung und zuwanderung
bis zum volkstod ausgibt der großteil
dieses hauses trägt diesen irrsinn mit
und noch eine kraft wehrt sich dagegen
nehme ich die alternative für
deutschland vielen dank
marianna h der könig aus der fdp
fraktion und auch sie sagt nicht dass
die ursache der energiekrise im krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine liegt und
die damit verbundenen liefer
reduzierungen beziehungsweise sogar der
lieferstopp von russischem gas nach
deutschland
claudia raffelhüschen ist die nächste
rednerin aus der fdp-fraktion wir haben
jetzt wieder eine runde mit raus eltern
die sich zum haushalt des einzel plans
der familienministerin äußern nein ich
gehe da jetzt nicht auf
schon zum zweiten mal in diesem jahr
beraten wir ein haushaltsentwurf für den
einzelplan 17 und um die banalste wie
bittere wahrheit gleich am anfang
auszusprechen die rahmenbedingungen sind
im vergleich zum haushalt
222 nicht besser geworden gerade deshalb
bin ich jedenfalls sehr froh dass wir am
ehrgeizigen ziele unseres
koalitionsvertrages festhalten und die
schuldenbremse ab diesem haushalt 23
wieder einhalten
[Applaus]
denn wir haben einerseits alle dass die
weltpolitische situation und sicherlich
noch auf jahre hinaus massenhaft gründe
geben würde viel staatliches geld zu
verausgaben und vieles an
finanzpolitischer vernunft über bord zu
werfen
andererseits wird uns gerade brutal vor
augen geführt was exzessive schulden
machen und die geldflut uns politik der
ezb
galoppierende inflation lohn preis
spiralen und wie in den usa oder
osteuropa zu besichtigen die anfänge
einer wirtschaftsrezession mit allen
unschönen nebenwirkungen für innere
sicherheit und politische stabilität
insofern also gut dass wir in
deutschland eine schuldenbremse haben
und sie nun auch wieder nutzen ich freue
mich sehr dass der einzelplan 17 trotz
der widrigen gesunden gesamtumstände im
vergleich zum soll
2022 um zwei 180,6 millionen euro steigt
und nun bei knapp 13 milliarden euro
liegt die größte steigerung mit einem
plus von 550 millionen gibt es beim
elterngeld das ist ein gutes signal
bestätigt wieder dass das elterngeld
eine der am meisten geschätzten
familienleistungen in deutschland ist
wir erreichen damit drei dinge
gleichzeitig wir sichern die
wirtschaftliche existenz der familie
wir entlasten eltern was oft vergessen
wird auch die unternehmen bei der
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf und
wir ermöglichen eltern und zwar beiden
eltern sich zeit für hinzunehmen der
kinderzuschlag steigt um 1 100 und 1
millionen auch das ist eine
familienleistung die im leben der
betroffenen kinder ein positiven
unterschied macht auch wenn wir uns alle
einig sind dass sie spät folgen der
pandemie gerade bei kindern und
jugendlichen noch längst nicht
überwunden sind kann die konsequenz
dennoch nicht sein dass wir uns im
dritten jahr der pandemie immer weiter
in einem ausnahme zustand einrichten der
heute gott sei dank nicht mehr so
gegeben ist wie noch vor zwei jahren um
diese zeit dass wir ohne lockdown
homeschooling auch kein programm corona
auszeit für familien mehr haben ist kein
trauriges zeichen sondern ein sehr gutes
für mich als freie liberale decken sich
hier finanz und gesellschaftspolitische
ziele ich wünsche mir für unsere kinder
mehr normalität und weniger
sondermaßnahmen an dieser stelle ein
ganz großes dankeschön an die ministerin
pause und stark watzinger dafür dass sie
sich so klar gegen weitere kita und
schließung ausgesprochen haben die
kosten
die kosten die durch noch mehr
psychische schäden bei kindern
garantiert entstehen würden können wir
uns wirklich im sinne des wortes sparen
gerne investieren wir dagegen in eine
gute kinderbetreuung und frühkindliche
bildung vor allem sprachkompetenz der
bund hat seit 2008 satte 5,4 milliarden
euro in den kita ausbau gesteckt und
seit 2009 10 noch mal 5,5 milliarden in
die umsetzung des gute kita gesetzes für
die weiterentwicklung dieses gesetzes
sind für 23 und 24 noch mal jeweils zwei
milliarden euro vorgesehen und das alles
obwohl
kinderbetreuung grundsätzlich erst
einmal ländersache ist und vor diesem
hintergrund finde ich die künstliche
empörung der letzten woche über das
planmäßige auslaufen des bundesprogramms
sprach peters nach sage und schreibe elf
jahren einigermaßen befremdlich
zumindest zeigt sie von einem sehr
seltsam föderalismus verständnis der
bund zahlt und die länder bestimmen hier
würde ich mir neben den grundsätzen der
haushaltsklarheit und haushaltswahrheit
zusätzlich den grundsatz der haushalt
fairness wünschen
in der vergangenheit haben leider viele
länder bundesgelder genutzt und kita
gebühren und zwar unabhängig vom
einkommen der eltern zu kürzen oder ganz
abzuschaffen
wenig überraschend wenig überraschend
hat nun die evaluation ergeben dass eine
stärkere priorisierung auf die
verbesserung der qualität gelegt werden
es heute darunter die verbesserung des
betreuungsschlüssels
qualifiziertes fachpersonal und für mich
ganz zentral die sprachliche bildung ich
bin daher froh dass die länder mit der
weiterentwicklung des kita qualitäts
gesetzes künftig überwiegend also über
50 prozent der gelder und die sieben
vorrangige handlungsfelder
investieren sollen aus meiner sicht
dürften es gerne 100 prozent sein die in
die qualität gesteckt werden
in diesem sinne freue ich mich auf die
weiteren beratung und unseren
gemeinsamen einsatz für die kinder und
die familie vielen dank
claudia raffelhüschen aus der
fdp-fraktion wir sind immer noch im
einzelplan 17 familie senioren frauen
und jugend und dazu spricht jetzt gesine
lötzsch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und
haushaltspolitischen sprecher
kinder sind in unserem land ein großes
armutsrisiko insbesondere für
alleinerziehende
das ist eine schande und das muss
geändert werden meine damen und herren
und auch das kinderhilfswerk unicef hat
der bundesregierung ins stammbuch
geschrieben die bundesregierung tut zu
wenig um kinder vor armut und gewalt zu
schützen die politik müsse endlich deren
wohl in den mittelpunkt stellen die
kollegin raffelhüschen von der fdp hat
gerade noch einmal in die unsinnige
schuldenbremse verteidigt und sie unter
die überschrift
generationengerechtigkeit gestellt die
wahrheit ist genau andersherum die
schuldenbremse ist eine zukunfts bremse
sie gefährdet die zukunft unserer kinder
und enkelkinder sie verhindert dass bach
den bau von kitas schulen und
infrastruktur und das gerecht die
schuldenbremse gehört wirklich auf den
müllhaufen der geschichte
frau aus sie haben hier wieder über die
einführung der kinder grund sich vom
besprochen ein wichtiges projekt das ihn
sicher bestimmt persönlich am herzen
liegt aber sie haben es in diesem
haushalt nicht durchgesetzt und ich
finde es ist doch unerträglich das ist
der ampel gelungen ist innerhalb von 100
tagen 100 milliarden euro für die
rüstung blogger zu machen und vier jahre
soll es dauern bis die
kindergrundsicherung kommt wer soll so
eine politik ernst nehmen dass es
garantiert keine politik für kinder und
jugendliche das muss sich ändern meine
damen und herren kinder und jugendliche
sind immer die ersten opfer in der krise
in der pandemie wurden als erstes die
spielplätze und dann die schulen
geschlossen und in der aktuellen
gaskrise bei einer der ersten vorschläge
von bundesinnenminister habe doch die
öffentlichen schwimmbäder nicht mehr zu
beheizen ich finde dass es ein fataler
vorschlag denn kein mitglied dieser
regierung hat gefordert zum beispiel
übungsflüge der luftwaffe zu reduzieren
um schreibt schreibt doch zu sparen nur
eine zahl das kampfflugzeug f 35
verbraucht in der stunde 5600 liter
treibstoff das ist doch nicht zu
akzeptieren das könnten wir einsetzen um
zu kinder und jugendliche etwas
sinnvolles zu machen meine damen und
herren
und das hat eine unheimliche symbolkraft
wenn die ampel jetzt das programm für
sprach kitas streicht mit diesem
programm hat der bund seit vielen jahren
das ist ja erwähnt wurden zusätzliches
personal für die sprachentwicklung in
kind peters finanziert in den
vergangenen jahren haben viele
einrichtungen davon profitiert und wenn
jetzt dieses beliebte programm
abgewickelt werden soll angeblich
weiterentwickelt aber das steht ja nicht
im selben haushalt drin dann ist das ein
fatales signal es kostet den bund gerade
einmal 200 millionen euro ein witz im
vergleich zu den
64,5 milliarden euro die die bundeswehr
allein in diesem jahr bekommt sagt ihm
mal ein zahlenvergleich wenn sie nur ein
weniger bauen würden dann hätten sie das
geld für diese sprachprogramm zusammen
meine damen und herren jedes fünfte kind
in deutschland gilt als armutsgefährdet
das ist nicht nur sozial ungerecht
sondern ist auch schlecht für die
gesellschaft sie kann sich dadurch
schlechter entwickeln vielen dank
gesine lötzsch für die linksfraktion in
der debatte zum einzelplan 17 bzw
beziehungsweise dessen etat und wir
sehen und hören als nächsten dem bruder
höhe fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen des
familienministeriums wächst an und das
in einer schwierigen zeit im vergleich
zum 22er haushalt steigen die ausgaben
um 280 millionen insgesamt also rund
12,9 milliarden für familien vom kita
bis ins rentenalter aber eben auch für
unsere lebendige demokratie und den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt das ist
zuallererst einmal ein gutes signal zur
richtigen zeit liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
eine ernsthafte analyse des einzel plans
muss im kontext der fiskalpolitischen
gesamtsituation erfolgen und damit eben
auch im angesicht der krise denen wir
gegenüberstehen und genau das führt uns
zu zwei realitäten die ich ja kurz
umreißen möchte die haushaltslage ist
angespannt das wissen sie alle wir haben
durch den krieg in der ukraine unsere
humanitären und sicherheitspolitischen
verpflichtungen aber eben auch durch die
teuerung und die massiven entlastung die
wir finanzieren massive mehrausgaben nun
reduzieren wir aber trotz dieser
mehrausgaben die nettokreditaufnahme von
139 milliarden auf 17 milliarden um die
schuldenbremse einhalten zu können das
erfordert natürlich eine gewisse
ausgaben kritik und davon ist der
einzelplan sitzen eben auch nicht
ausgenommen die zweite realität ist eine
enorme diskrepanz der haushaltssituation
von bund und ländern im mai 22 hatte die
länder gesamtheit ein positives
finanzierungssaldo von 11,3 milliarden
die tatsache ist die länder haben die
finanzielle ausstattung um ihre
landeseigenen aufgaben auch zu schultern
und
vor diesem hintergrund dieser beiden
realitäten die ich geschrieben habe
verstehe ich auch die angriffe der union
hier nicht sie können nicht auf der
einen seite in sonntagsreden immer die
schwarze null hoch halten aber auf der
anderen seite im parlamentarischen
haushaltsverfahren fordern jeden zweiten
titel im haushalt zu erhöhen das passt
nicht zusammen dafür muss man kein
mathematiker sein und festzustellen dass
das nicht geht das ist unseriös
das ist eine unseriöse haushaltspolitik
liebe kolleginnen zu den sprach kitas
hat die ministerin schon ausgeführt klar
ist dass wir über das kita qualitäts
gesetz und den schwerpunktbereich
sprachförderung den ländern die
möglichkeit geben das programm
weiterzuführen sie müssen diese
möglichkeiten eben nutzen und genau
dafür hat die ministerin hart verhandelt
damit wir unser versprechen das kita
qualitäts gesetz auf den weg zu bringen
einlösen können das ist gelungen
insgesamt vier milliarden stellen wir
dafür in 2000 23 und 24 bereit das ist
nötig weil kind kitas eben nicht nur ein
ob der betreuung sind sondern vor allem
auch ein ort frühkindlicher bildung und
sozialisation der ort wo das fundament
für chancengerechtigkeit gelegt wird
unser motto ist klar und einfach
qualität ist priorität und genau das
prägt das kita qualitäts gesetzt
ein weiterer erfolg ist das
zukunftspaket für bewegung kultur und
gesundheit im umfang von 50 millionen
euro die ministerin sorgt dafür dass die
erfolge der ausgelaufenen corona
programme nicht einfach versickern
sichert eine anschlussfinanzierung und
das unterstützen wir natürlich weil es
geboten ist nach jahren der entbehrungen
aufgrund der korona situation vor allem
für unsere jüngsten liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen lassen sie mich
abschließend sagen das ministerium hat
weniger handlungsspielraum als in den
letzten jahren obwohl an sich mehr geld
zur verfügung steht 2023 fliesen 550
millionen mehr in das elterngeld der
wachsende ansatz ist gut im sinne der
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf die
wir ja gemeinsam auch massiv fördern
aber der titel bindet eben auch
haushaltsmittel die dann im
programmbereich fehlen am ende sind wir
also wieder bei der realität vom an
unter einhaltung der schuldenbremse sind
abstriche an einigen stellen
unumgänglich trotzdem finanzieren wir
das notwendige gehen darüber hinaus mit
diesem einzelplan mit dem kita qualitäts
gesetz wir haben jetzt im
parlamentarischen verfahren noch
handlungsspielräume wir sollten sie
nutzen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der nicht zu reden für die cdu csu
fraktion ist der kollege dr hermann
josef tebroke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auf den rängen und den
empfangsgeräten wer als cdu/csu werden
nicht müde die bedeutung der wert der
familie immer wieder heraus zu stellen
und uns auch in der politik ganz konkret
für familie einzusetzen
insofern begrüßen wir natürlich auch die
debatte zu dem einzelplan 17 wobei
gerade schon deutlich gemacht worden ist
dass der einzelplan 17 und das was dort
abgebildet ist nicht alleine das
ausmacht was familie betrifft bei der
damen und herren was ist von familien in
den zug in das wirkliche könner krise
alles geleistet erlitten worden wo wären
wir als staat eigentlich wenn wir die
familien nicht hätten die so viel auch
für uns als staat als gesellschaft
geleistet haben und jetzt kommt die
ukraine krise die energiekrise die
inflation es kommen zukunft drängt sie
dazu wieder sind es familien und gerade
mit kindern zu machen in mehreren
kindern das sind alleinerziehende
familien fliegenden angehörigen die
überproportional betroffen sind zum
einen weil die preissteigerung vor allem
produkte und dienstleistungen betreffen
die von familien nachgefragt werden und
zum anderen weil familien im
durchschnitt ein geringeres einkommen
zur verfügung haben und damit diese
krise nicht so leicht wegstecken können
ich glaube darüber besteht weitestgehend
einigkeit und es wird auch viele orte
immer wieder anerkennung zum ausdruck
gebracht wir sagen aber es braucht auch
konkrete unterstützung zwar schneller
und mehr als das hier geplant ist vor
diesem hintergrund legt die ampel legte
die regierung einen haushaltsplanentwurf
2023 vor der
als wie sagte der staatssekretär donker
als gute grundlage für die
parlamentarische beratung dienen möge
das macht deutlich dass auch hier die
fdp der finanzminister davon ausgeht
ausgehen muss dass noch intensiv
nachgebessert werden muss und wenn und
das möchte ich an dieser stelle sofort
auch klarstellen in richtung von herrn
dr fliegt auch von veröffentlichen sagen
wenn dafür die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse portiert wird dann
geschieht das auch in uns mit unserer
unterstützung weil wir glauben grad auch
sich der familie gehört zu einer
nachhaltigen politik eben auch die
berücksichtigung der nachfolgenden
generation liegen dass abzutragen hat
was wir hier möglicherweise leicht
fertig verausgaben
aber meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
ist dieses wuchtige paket mehr als
wichtig ist es eigentlich auch klug und
vor allem ist es familienfreundlich und
das ist eine frage die ich insbesondere
an sie frau familienministerin richten
möchte und dabei meine ich nicht nur die
analyse und bewertung des einzelplan 17
ich glaube familienpolitik geht weit
über das hinaus und ihre verantwortung
reicht weit über das hinaus was im
einzelplan 10 abgebildet wird familien
brauchen infrastruktur brauchen zeit
aber sie brauchen auch konkret geld und
ich möchte an dieser stelle insbesondere
auf die steuerpolitischen beiträge
eingehen die hat dazu auch angelegt sein
können familie zumal in dieser situation
zu unterstützen und es macht mich
zuversichtlich frau aus als ehemaliges
mitglied des finanzausschusses und
insbesondere auch mit steuerpolitischen
fragen dass sie sehr
konstruktiv mit den vorschlägen umgehen
die wir als union unterbreiten möchten
konkret auf steuerpolitische fragen bei
der gestaltung des steuersystems das was
in zukunft auch hier zu beraten ist
warum gelingt es nicht mehr und
konsequenter auch die liste der
mit ermäßigten steuersätzen belegten
umsätze zu diskutieren zu untersuchen
gerade aus sicht der familie was ist mit
den lebensmittel die man noch mit 19
prozent besteuert werden was ist mit
hygieneartikeln zur versorgung von
kindern was mit der kinderkleidung und
kinderschuhen die wir mit sieben prozent
steuern konnten statt mit 19 ein
schneller beitrag zur hilfe familie ich
komme zum zweiten punkt was ist mit
ersparnis hilfen für familien für junge
familien könnten wir neben unterstützung
etwa im bereich da aber nehmer
sparzulage der wohnungsbauprämie
nicht auch mehr macht und im bereich der
grunderwerbsteuer freibeträge um
vermögen zu bilden was ist mit der
erhöhung des sparer pauschbetrag für
kleine sparer für familien die vermögen
bilden wollen und sich damit schützen
wollen vor inflationsrisiken
oder das dritte das machen wir sehr gern
dr freaky wir helfen ihnen dabei wenn
das so noch nicht von ihm vorbereitet
wir haben auch einige vorschläge zur
einkommensteuer wir haben einen wir
könnten uns einen energiekosten
freibetrag vorstellen darüber gibt es
einen vorschlag als alternative zu dem
300 euro für alle paket wir stellen uns
eine anpassung der kinderfreibeträge vor
auch eine anpassung der des kindergeldes
in die kollegin bea hatte bereits darauf
hingewiesen dass wir nicht
nachvollziehen können wie da
argumentiert wird wir haben
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten im bereich
der haushaltsnahen dienstleistungen
völlig chaotisch organisiert lassen sie
uns das aktualisieren lassen sie uns das
straffen ich glaube wir tun viel für die
familie und nicht zuletzt die
alleinerziehenden zu entlasten hatten
wir wiederholt vorgeschlagen ich
verstehe eigentlich auch die fraktion
der linken nicht die ja hier faules
betont wie sehr die alleinerziehenden
hier ein herz legen aber die
unterstützung für unsere anträge
schuldig bleibt meine damen und herren
familienzentren einwendung und sie
brauchen mehr unterstützung frau
präsidentin vor ministerin wir erwarten
von ihnen dass sie über die ansätze im
einzelplan 17 hinaus mehr für familien
erkennbar tun zum beispiel im bereich
der steuerpolitik und wir versichern
ihnen ihre unterstützung wir sind eine
konstruktive opposition vergessen
alle familien gelegentlich tat vielen
dank für die
hermann josef tebroke aus der
unionsfraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
in dieser red kaiser aus der spd
fraktion
sie ist mitglied im ausschuss für
familie senioren frauen und jugend aber
auch sprecherin für strategien gegen
rechtsextremismus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
sehr geehrte bürgerinnen und bürger
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mit blick
auf den herbst und winter ist für uns in
der spd ist klar wir tun alles dafür den
herausforderungen infolge des russischen
angriffskriegs insbesondere den enormen
energiepreisen wirksam zu begegnen denn
nur so sichern wir den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft
mit den beschlüssen vom wochenende hat
die koalition einmal mehr bewiesen dass
sie in zeiten großer krisen
handlungsfähig ist und dass sich
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem land
auf uns verlassen können die aufweitung
des wohngeldanspruch cent eine
strompreis bremse steigerungen beim
kinderzuschlag und kindergeld endlich
300 euro direktzahlungen für
rentnerinnen und rentner 200 euro für
studierende und fachschüler innen all
das und mehr sind maßnahmen die vor
allem familien beziehen von kleinen
mittleren einkommen aber auch menschen
im alter zielgenau entlasten
als aus thüringerin sind wir das
besonders wichtige anliegen weiß ich
doch um die kurs teils immer noch
geringeren löhne geringeren wenden und
kaum vorhandenen vermögen die man
bräuchte um die preissteigerung in folge
von und inflation und die hohen
energiekosten abfedern zu können wir
müssen aber damit rechnen dass die
aktuelle lage länger andauert als wir
alle hoffen die nun bevorstehende
beratungen zum bundeshaushalt 20 23
stehen deshalb auch weiterhin im zeichen
dieser enormen herausforderungen und
klar ist dabei auch dass bund und länder
gemeinsam
in der verantwortung stehen die folgen
der krise zu bewältigen
das trifft auch
auf viele bereiche des
bundesfamilienministeriums zu tun mit
blick auf den haushalt 20 23 für das
bundesministerium für familie frauen
senioren und jugend verlässt sich
zunächst feststellen dass die mittel um
280 millionen euro steigen und das
obwohl die gelder aus dem koma auf höhe
programm auslaufen gründe dafür sind
dass mehr menschen gesetzliche
leistungen die
elterngeldanspruch in anspruch nehmen
und aber auch von verbesserten
unterhaltsvorschuss und kinderzuschlag
profitieren und das ist gut so denn mit
den gesetzlichen familienleistungen
erreichen wie eine bessere vereinbarkeit
von familie und beruf zu unterstützen
alleinerziehende und wir helfen familien
mit geringen einkommen und zugleich ist
unser part spd wichtig dass mehr getan
werden muss um kinder davor zu schützen
in armut aufzuwachsen
die kindergrundsicherung das ist eine
leistung die wir bündeln wollen
unbürokratisch zusammenführen wollen für
kinder das ist das größte projekt auch
mit unserer koalition mit der
kinderarmut effektiv bekämpfen wollen
alles und kinder das ist aber nicht nur
der mangel an monetären ressourcen
sondern oft verbunden mit bildungsarmut
entwicklungsdefiziten sowie typischen
sozialen störungen
studien belegen kinder aus armen
familien bleiben häufig ihr ganzes leben
lang an und das darf nicht sein an
kindern und jugendlichen dürfen wir
nicht sparen
euro die seitens des bundes für die
weiterentwicklung des gute kita gesetzes
beziehungsweise für das kita qualitäts
gesetz in den kommenden zwei jahren zur
verfügung stehen sind deshalb ein
wichtiger und richtiger posten für die
kinder in unserem land
positiv positiv möchte ich auch die 50
millionen euro für das neue
zukunftspaket bewegungskultur und
gesundheit angehen denn das ist gut
angelegtes geld um einsamkeit
bewegungsmangel von kindern und
jugendlichen zu begegnen und in dieser
frühen lebensphase nachhaltig zu
unterstützen frau kaiser möchten sie
eine zwischenfrage von frau bär zu
lassen wie schön
zusammenhalt gemeinschaft und teilhabe
so wichtig dass für kinder und
jugendliche ist wenn sie sich zum
beispiel in sportvereinen engagieren so
wichtig ist es auch für unsere
demokratie erst das vielfältige
zivilgesellschaftliche engagement macht
demokratie lebendig und wehrhaft gerade
mit blick auf die erstarkenden
demokratiefeindlichen kräfte gilt es
dieses engagement zu unterstützen in
diesem zusammenhang freue ich mich
persönlich sehr dass der titel für
demokratieförderung und extremismus
prävention 20 23 um weitere 16,5
millionen euro aufgestockt
damit
stehen in diesem land insgesamt 200
millionen euro bereit ein rekordwert und
ein tolles signal für die vielen
menschen in unserem land die sich
tagtäglich wird demokratie engagieren
und wo licht ist da ist manchmal auch
schatten und der entwurf enthält noch
einige punkte mit denen ich noch nicht
ganz zufrieden bin und so werden zum
beispiel die mittel für die an schulen
so wichtige arbeit der respekt coaches
sowie die jugend migrationsdienst die
wir zusätzlich und 22 mit verhandelt
haben jetzt nicht mehr fortgeschrieben
insgesamt sinken die ausgaben für die
kinder und für den kinder- und
jugendplan dem wichtigsten
förderinstrument auf bundesebene im
bereich der kinder- und jugendhilfe und
das nicht so ein ding auslaufen der
korona hilfen sollten aber immer auch
die folgenden blick behalten die solche
kürzungen nach sich ziehen und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir in der einen
oder anderen stelle da noch nachbessern
können und freue mich auf die beratung
und die gute zusammenarbeit vielen dank
herr
kollegin bea gebe ich das wort für eine
kurzintervention ja liebe frau kollegin
kaiser schade dass ihr meine kurzen und
knappen nachfragen die ihnen auch noch
mal die möglichkeit gegeben hätten
vielleicht zu sagen was sie vorher nicht
zugelassen haben deswegen an dieser
stelle zum einen würde uns sehr
interessieren wenn das thema
kindergrundsicherung immer so ein ganz
großes thema ist wie sie es finden das
noch nicht mal alle arbeitsgruppen
getagt haben der regierung schon ein
bisschen zeit ins land gegangen punkt
zwei wie bewerten sie das um den umgang
mit dem dritten und vierten und fünften
kind was meine kollegin bringe ja auch
schon aufgeworfen hat also zählen nur
erste und zweite kinder was ich
besonders persönlich ganz schade finde
für alle die wirklich kinderreiche
familien sind und das dritte ist wer hat
recht in ihrer fraktion frau kollegin
kaiser sie oder herr von malottki wenn
wirklich das thema sprach kitas kein
problem es warum gibt es dann eine
petition ihres kollegen der direkt neben
ihnen sitzt also vielleicht können sie
das mal auflösen innerhalb ihrer
fraktion der wenn wir sehr daran
interessiert
[Applaus]
zur antwort frau kaiser
wir sind uns eigentlich dass uns
familien und kinder diesem land sehr
wichtig sind ich denke sie sollten die
ihr gesetz geben das verfahren jetzt
abwarten zur kindergrundsicherung da
sind wir auf einem guten weg und zu der
anderen fragen ein bisschen dass alle
kinder in diesem land wichtig und gerade
auch die sprache dass das habe ich auch
meiner letzten haushaltsrede sehr
deutlich gemacht und ich habe auch
erwähnen das sind bund und länder
gemeinsam in der pflicht will setzt das
fort indem wir eben auch die zwei
milliarden für 20 23 und 24 einstellen
in den bundeshaushalt und denken dass
wir dann guten weg finden dass da keine
erzieherin kein erzieher keine pädagogen
keine pädagogen angst haben muss dass es
nicht weitergeht
für die art des nächste rednerin ulrike
schicke zu sehen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte frau
ministerin meine damen und herren das
zweite mal in diesem jahr debattieren
wir den haushalt des
familienministeriums das zweite mal in
einem jahr in dem viele familien mit
sorge in die zukunft schauen und
natürlich erwarten die familien von
ihnen frau ministerin dass es in dieser
krise entlastungen gibt dass es helfen
gibt für die familien und für die kinder
um die krise für sie abzufedern aber
leider ist der haushalt in dieser
hinsicht eine große enttäuschung
der etat für familien ist um fast 250
millionen euro gewachsen damit rühmt
sich die ganze koalition gewachsen ist
aber etat lediglich wegen der
gesetzlichen leistungen sie wissen ganz
genau dass diese automatisch steigen
dass es nicht ihre politik das sind per
gesetz errechnete leistungen aller in
der unterhaltsvorschuss und das
elterngeld steigen um circa 600
millionen euro man muss kein mathe genie
sein um festzustellen dass die 600
millionen nicht gleich sind mit den 250
millionen mehr bei den allgemeinen
ausgaben andersrum ihr ministerium hat
ordentlich gespart aber wo genau zum
beispiel in der kinder- und
jugendpolitik ganze 470 millionen - 400
man da das sind die bereiche der freien
jugendhilfe die qualifizierungsoffensive
oder einsparungen bei den stiftungen
frühe hilfen allein bei den sogenannten
sprach geht das indem kita
einstiegsprogramm wurde ordentlich
gekürzt mehr als 260 millionen ja die
programme laufen aus haben wir schon
gehört aber das muss kein automatismus
sein hier wäre eine politische
entscheidung fällig hier könnten sie
zeigen dass ihnen die kita kinder nicht
egal sind es ist eine politische
entscheidung gewesen diese programme
auslaufen zu lassen und es den einzelnen
ländern zu übertragen ob sie es gerne
machen würden oder nicht und es ist eine
falsche politische entscheidung
das einzige plus dass man übrigens in
diesem kapitel findet ist der neu
geschaffene titel für ein zukunftspaket
für bewegung kultur und gesundheit
während wir als auch die fraktion diesen
titel zumindest im ansatz
unterstützenswert finden ist das volumen
doch ein schlechter scherz ausgerechnet
der titel der die vergeigte burgunder
politik der vorgängerregierung
und mit lauter aber auch dieser
regierung ausgleichen soll soll mit nur
50 millionen euro die immensen schäden
die bei den kindern entstanden sind
ausgleichen das ist nichts ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein immerhin ein funken
reue wird darin ersichtlich die rechnung
aber dürfen mal wieder die familien
größtenteils alleine tragen ähnlich ist
es auch mit ihrem großen wurf
kinderzuschlag 21 euro mehr im monat 21
euro der großteil der familien nicht
bekommt da die voraussetzungen so eng
geschnitten sind 21 euro die bei einer
realen inflation ein witz sind diese 21
euro sind in diesen tagen einen hohen
für viele familien lieber ampel auch die
nun versprochenen 18 euro mehr
kindergeld können die folgen der
inflation für die familien nicht mal
ansatzweise lindern wie diese erhöhung
finanziert wird die insgesamte vielen
versprechen der ampel für das nächste
entlastungs paket finanziert werden
sollen steht in den sternen wir werden
sehen ob der finanzminister bis zur
verabschiedung des haushalts einen weg
zur finanzierung gefunden hat frau
ministerin ich kann mich noch sehr gut
daran erinnern wie wir im dezember
letzten jahres an dieser stelle über
unsere vorschläge zur bekämpfung der
sich bereits damals anbahnenden
inflation diskutiert haben damals waren
sie zwar noch nicht ministerin aber
immerhin die finanzpolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion
und was haben sie uns damals erzählt
dass die inflation zitat erstaunlich
wenig beträgt mehr noch gemeinsam mit
ihrer koalitionskollegen frau käthe von
der spd haben sie doch allen ernstes vor
der deflation gewarnt und allgemein die
entwicklung schön geredet ich glaube
mittlerweile muss es aber in den aller
länder ryan ihrer koalition angekommen
sein wie verteilt falsch ihrer
einschätzung und finanzexperte war und
wie sehr sie die gefahren der inflation
unterschätzt haben übrigens all dies war
weit vor dem überfall auf die ukraine
mir scheint als ob die ukraine krise
mittlerweile zu einem idealen sündenbock
für alles was seit längerem schon schief
läuft geworden ist das soll von den
eigentlichen problemen ablenken nämlich
dass es ihre regierungspolitik ist und
war die uns in diese lage gebracht hat
und sie haben anscheinend auch nicht
viel daraus gelernt
anders kann ich mir die weiteren
falschen entscheidungen wie etwa die
gasanlage oder die inzwischen völlig
verfehlte sanktionspolitik nicht
erklären diese bewusste entscheidung
oder das völlige leuten von problemen
bringen inzwischen unzählige familien an
den rand der verzweiflung das ist bitter
und das muss auch gesagt werden meine
damen und herren es wird viel zu
besprechen sein in den
haushaltsberatungen
ich kann für mich und meine fraktion
ankündigen dass wir eine reihe an
anträgen stellen werden wo wir mehr
ausgaben sehen wollen etwa bei den
entlastungen der familien auf der
anderen seite gibt es viele positionen
in denen wir kürzen werden etwa da wo
geld sinnlos verfeuert wird frau
ministerin über ampel regierung wir
leben in turbulenten zeiten es ist
allerhöchste zeit dass sie die
scheuklappen ihrer ideologie ablegen und
entsprechend ihrem amtseid handel vielen
dank
[Applaus]
die die jensen hat jetzt das wort für
die fdp-fraktion und goethe jensen ist
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fdp-fraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zu der vorrednerin dfb hätte
ich am liebsten gesagt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der fraktion regieren wir
doch einfach so dass die afg damit ein
riesiges problem hätte und ich glaube
dann sind wir auf einem guten weg liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir als
immer und jugendpolitik politiker hier
über den haushalt sprechen dann haben
wir hier immer ein ganz grundlegenden
konflikt präsent den vielleicht der ein
oder andere auch erst wieder bemerkt hat
seitdem die fdp in dieser
bundesregierung vertreten ist und zwar
unsere schuldenlast ist eine hypothek
für kommende generationen
wir haben die verantwortung unseren
kindern staatsfinanzen zu hinterlassen
und sie nicht noch mit weiteren ballast
zu belasten denn die herausforderungen
für die nächsten generationen die verben
nicht geringer werden gut an dieser
stelle dass wir einen finanzminister
haben der auf das geld achtet und auch
eine bundesregierung die genau diesem
kurs des finanzministers folgt und den
mitgeht und dann ist da die andere seite
und sei die seite die wir glaube ich
hier auch alle unterschreiben könnten
nämlich dass jeder euro in die zukunft
von kindern und jugendlichen eine
investition in die zukunft ist eine
investition auch in eine gerechtere
gesellschaft denn gute startbedingungen
machen kinder stark und sie stellen vor
allem die weichen für ein leben voller
chancen und deshalb sind die mittel im
etat gegenüber dem bisherigen finanzplan
gestiegen und zwar obwohl mittel aus dem
koma auf vollprogramm obwohl aus dem
ergänzungs haushalt mit dem auslaufen
ich glaube das ist eine wunderbare
nachricht
zusätzlich investieren aber nicht nur
aus dem etat für das fbn fsj in gute
startchancen für die kinder sondern eben
auch aus dem finanzministerium da kommen
für das kita qualitäts gesetz dass hier
schon entsprechend mehrfach erwähnung
fand vier milliarden euro in den
nächsten zwei jahren also eine
maßgebliche unterstützung für beste
kitas und zwar überall in deutschland
des hat die ministerin gesagt als freie
demokraten haben wir schon lange
gefordert dass die bundesmittel in
teilhabe in qualität in der kita
betreuung investiert werden anstatt in
pauschale gebührenfreiheit und diese
beitragsfreiheit die wird ja gerne in
wahlkämpfen genutzt aber ich glaube wir
sind uns hier in der koalition einig
dass vor allen dingen dieses überwiegend
und meine kollegin claudia filmisches
angesprochen dass mehr als 50 prozent in
qualität gehen ein unglaublich wichtiges
zeichen ist und das schreiben wir jetzt
in das setzt in das qualitäts gesetz und
sorgen dafür dass tatsächlich auch in
deutschland standards gesetzt werden wir
unterstützen dabei nämlich genau dort
dass kinder in die kita gehen könnte
unabhängig vom wohnort unabhängig vom
einkommen ihrer eltern und zwar in eine
kita die personell gut ausgestattet ist
auf individuelle bedürfnisse der kinder
eingeht und flexible betreuungszeiten
bietet und im übrigen es wird manchmal
in solchen debatten vergessen in solchen
einrichtungen arbeitet es sich ja auch
viel lieber also auch die erzieherin
erzieher pädagoginnen und pädagogen die
haben lust in solchen einrichtungen
ihren beitrag zu leisten weil diese
möglichkeiten und die rahmenbedingungen
gegeben sind und die vielen
angesprochenen sprach kitas ja wir
ermöglichen den ländern dass sie diese
bundesmittel zum beispiel in der
sprachförderung nutzen und hören sie auf
in der union jetzt die sich hier so zu
tun als würden sprach kitas abgeschafft
werden übrigens gerade deswegen endlich
hier sitzen und dann miteinander darüber
streiten in diesem haushalt das ist
wichtig ist draußen zu erklären was hier
eigentlich passiert und ich erlebe
momentan eher eine angst in den
verbänden bei erzieherinnen und
erziehern die sagen uns wird gesagt
unser job ist weg sorgten sie helfen sie
uns doch dabei dafür zu sagen nein
helfen sie uns dabei dass die mittel mit
den ländern sie sind doch in den ländern
präsent an günter schleswig-holstein
beispielsweise inklusive abend sorgen
sie dafür dass sie gemeinsam dass sie
gemeinsam der mitte ja im verhältnis
sogar aufwachsen können bei mehr in
qualität investiert werden kann genau
für sprachförderung eingesetzt wird wenn
sie auf uns in der koalition die wir
hier gemeinsam miteinander ringen um die
beste förderung für kinder obwohl der
grundgesetzlich nicht mehr zuständig
wären dafür zu sorgen dass qualität in
den kitas genau und was passiert wenn
eine projekt was passiert wenn ein
erfolgreiches projekt in die
verstetigung geht wir haben das hier
schon gehört das bedeutet dass wir an
die länder die verantwortung übergeben
mit mitteln des bundes weiterhin
sprachförderung zu investieren und ich
finde es wirklich traurig dass sie hin
nicht eindeutig dazu stellung nehmen wir
freuen uns sehr auf die konstruktiven
haushaltsberatung aber wenn hier
menschen zuhören und nicht teil des
ausschuss der ausschussarbeit sind sie
nicht kann man hier auch mal erklären
was es am ende bedeutet in einer zeit wo
die haushaltslage extrem angespannt ist
dennoch jeden jedes jahr zwei milliarden
euro für die nächsten zwei jahre zur
verfügung zu haben und fest gesetzt zu
haben dass wir mehr in qualität in
sprachförderung investieren können ein
letzter punkt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir müssen dafür sorgen und ich
bin da der der ministerin auch der
bundesbildungsministerin sehr dankbar
dass wir dafür sorgen konnten in den
verhandlungserfolge jetzt was das
entlastungspaket angelangt dass vor
allen dingen auch der kinderzuschlag
anwächst das ist jetzt ein anderes thema
es wird hier viel von kindergelderhöhung
gesprochen aber vor allen dingen der
kinderzuschlag ist so zielgerichtet als
instrument und unterstützt familien die
zum beispiel sich eher über die sich
eher darüber gedanken machen müssen ich
komme zum schluss frau präsidentin das
nächste essen auf den tisch zu bringen
oder eine winterjacke zu kaufen und wir
freuen uns auf die beratungen die
konstruktiv sein mögen und ich hoffe
sehr dass er es schaffen draußen rück zu
melden was wir wirklich tun im sinne von
familien und auch im sinne der
straftäters
peter jensen von der fdp fraktion
verweist noch mal das hier ist natürlich
ein arbeits parlament und deswegen wird
ja viel arbeit auch da gemacht wo wir
sie nicht unbedingt übertragen in den
ausschüssen glück akbulut spricht jetzt
für die linksfraktion sich sprecherin
für familie liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen während viele familien kinder
und jugendliche noch mit den folgen der
korona krise kämpfen kürzt die
bundesregierung 40 prozent der ausgaben
für kinder- und jugendpolitik die rasant
steigende inflation treibt vor allem
geringverdienende familiennamen in die
arme der sofort zuschlag von 20 euro pro
kind wird von der inflation regelrecht
aufgefressen im moment wir hatten
bereits bei der einführung kritisiert
dass 20 euro viel zu gering sind auch
die angekündigte erhöhung des
kindergeldes um 18 euro für das erste
und zweite kind ist einfach lächerlich
das reicht ja nicht einmal für eine
massive windel packung und ab dem
dritten und vierten kind soll das ganze
auch überhaupt nicht mehr erhöht werden
und wer hartz iv bezieht frau aus hat
von der kindergelderhöhung ohnehin
nichts es ist einfach untragbar dass das
kindergeld mit dem hartz iv anspruch
wieder verrechnet wird
bildung für die bundeswehr wieder
gigantische summen in diesem haushalt
zur verfügung gestellt werden wird im
bildungs- und familienbereich weiterhin
gekürzt der kita bereich ist mit 20
milliarden seit jahren chronisch
unterfinanziert wir fordern daher ein
echtes kind kita qualitäts gesetzt was
seinen namen auch gerecht wird und vom
bund dauerhaft mitfinanziert wird es
kann nicht sein dass die seit jahren
steigenden kosten am ende der geschichte
wieder auf die kommunen und länder
abgewälzt werden außerdem ist es fatal
dass das
bundesprogramm sprach kitas nicht
weitergeführt wird betroffen von den
kürzungen sind über 500 25.000 kinder
und rund
6800 einrichtungen sprach kitas sind vor
allem dort zu finden wo familien mit
besonderen problemlagen oder
migrationsgeschichte leben die grünen
und die spd verschärft die bildungs
ungleichheit und brechen ihren eigenen
koalitionsvertrag
das bundesprogramm sollte mit jährlich
260 millionen frau aus wieder
fortgesetzt werden
sehr geehrte damen
das groß angekündigte und gefeierte
dritter entlastungspaket der ampel
parteien ist beim genauen hinsehen
völlig unzureichend und wird immer mehr
menschen in existenznöte drängen in den
nächsten monaten deswegen gehen wir als
linke auf die straße mit vielen
bündnispartnern und fordern lautstark
den weg in unsere einführung der
kollegin
[Musik]
zum schluss zu sehen
die straßen kollegen überlassen und die
sie mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der klub hat das wort für bündnis 90 die
grünen
in wiesloch ist obfrau im
familienausschuss für ihre partei
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen es sind schwierige zeiten um
über einen haushalt zu beraten der krieg
in der ukraine
die energiekrise und die immer noch
anhaltenden auswirkungen der korona
pandemie und gerade in dieser zeit mit
diesen herausforderungen halte ich einen
alten einhalten der schuldenbremse für
höchst fragwürdig und kontraproduktiv
denn wir müssen doch bewährte projekte
erhalten und fortführen damit wichtige
strukturen nicht wegbrechen mehr denn je
brauchen familien kinder und jugendliche
jetzt verlässliche unterstützung und
angebote
wie in ihrer rede schon erwähnt ist es
bundesfamilienministerin dieser post
gelungen viele dieser guten projekte und
angebote im regierungsentwurf
abzusichern und das zeigt auch in diesen
schwierigen zeiten bleiben wir als ampel
koalition handlungsfähig
[Applaus]
doch der massiven spardruck ist auch in
unserem einzelplan zu spüren für uns
parlamentarierin heißt es daher nun dass
wir die belange der menschen nicht
vergessen dürfen die im haushalt
ethischen debatten oft ich im
vordergrund stehen wir müssen uns daher
für notwendige vorhaben stark machen
deren finanzierung bisher noch nicht
gesichert ist ein beispiel für ein
solches vorhaben ist die kampagne der
unabhängigen beauftragten zu fragen des
sexuellen kindesmissbrauch diese
sensibilisierungskampagne ist bereits
fertig geplant und trotzdem sind bisher
keine mittel für die umsetzung und
weiterentwicklung im haushalt vorgesehen
deshalb möchte ich als mitglied im
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend an dieser stelle noch einmal
die bedeutung und die notwendigkeit
dieser kampagne hervorheben denn noch
immer werden jährlich tausende fälle
sexualisierter gewalt an kindern zur
anzeige gebracht aber ein weitaus
größerer anteil bleibt im dunkelfeld es
ist davon auszugehen dass in jeder
schulklasse und ein bis zwei kinder von
sexualisierter gewalt in ganz
unterschiedlichen kontexten betroffen
sind ob in der schule selbst in der
freizeit oder in der familie laut einer
forsa umfrage aus dem letzten herbst
hatten bis 90 prozent der befragten für
wahrscheinlich dass sexualisierte gewalt
an kindern vor allem in familien oder im
sozialen nahraum stattfindet und
gleichzeitig halten ist 85 prozent für
unwahrscheinlich oder sogar
ausgeschlossen dass es in der eigenen
familie beziehungsweise im engen umfeld
passiert oder passieren kann und diese
diskrepanz in der wahrnehmung bei
erwachsenen muss verändert werden und
ich spreche und
ich spreche ganz bewusst von erwachsenen
denn sie sind ist die kinder vor
sexualisierter gewalt schützen müssen
sie müssen für die anzeichen
sensibilisiert werden und vor allem das
handlungswissen haben dass sie dagegen
tun können
sexualisierte gewalt an kindern kann nur
verhindert werden wenn wir alle diesen
gedanken zu lassen dass es sehr wohl
auch die eigenen kinder oder kinder die
man kennt treffen kann und genau da
setzt diese kampagne der unabhängigen
beauftragten an neben der
sensibilisierung und aufklärung ist auch
die förderung von dialog und austausch
teil der kampagne
außerdem ist geplant dass lokale
netzwerke gegen sexualisierte gewalt
aufgebaut und dafür multiplikatoren
ausgebildet werden das ziel ist es
menschen zu befähigen gegen
sexualisierte gewalt aktiv zu werden
liebe kolleginnen die regierung hat
einen entwurf für den haushalt vorgelegt
aber letztendlich entscheidet das
parlament das ist unser hoheitsrecht da
können wir als parlamentarier in akzente
setzten die vier bewirken ich freue mich
wenn wir diesen kampf gegen
sexualisierte gewalt an kinder setzen
und 5 millionen in die
sensibilisierungskampagne investieren
das würde auch die wichtige arbeit der
unabhängigen beauftragten stärken und
wertschätzen ich freue mich auf gute
beratung vielen dank
an der ganzen hat jetzt das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und allianzen sitzt im
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir dürfen in diesem jahr
bereits zum zweiten mal über einen
entwurf des bundeshaushalts und damit
auch den einzelplan 17 debattieren und
selbstverständlich freue ich mich ein
halbes jahr nach dem haushalt 22 über
den gestiegenen gestiegenen etat für das
nächste jahr auch wenn dieser anstieg
verhältnismäßig klein es sind knapp 300
millionen euro viel geld wenn sie
sinnvoll und nachhaltig eingesetzt
werden und genau hier bedauere ich die
einschränkungen im bereich der überhaupt
für programme und förderung zur
verfügung stehenden mittel denn unsere
seniorinnen und senioren profitieren als
einzige zielgruppe des ministeriums
nicht von den festgesetzten gesetzlichen
leistungen und bilden auch sonst keinen
schwerpunkt in diesem entwurf immerhin
haben sie das thema einsamkeit zu einem
wichtigen vorhaben erklärt und das ist
eine richtige und notwendige
schwerpunktsetzung wir sind in diesem
zusammenhang auch ihre neuen maßnahmen
beziehungsweise eine konkrete maßnahme
nämlich die gründung des
kompetenznetzwerks einsamkeit nicht
entgangen warum sie aber im gleichen
zuge die zuschüsse und leistungen für
zwecke an träger und für aufgaben der
politik für ältere und einsame menschen
und knapp zwei millionen euro einkürzen
erschließt sich mir vor diesem
hintergrund nicht ich würde sogar sagen
dass sie hier ein deutlicher widerspruch
zwischen worten und zahlen ergibt im
juni 22 startete intern endlich die
arbeit an der auch von uns geplanten
strategie gegen einsamkeit das
strategiepapier benötigen aber doch noch
ein weiteres jahr und soll erst mitte
merken in mitte 23 vorliegen sollten sie
noch anregungen oder ideen benötigen
verweise stern auf unser bereits vor
anderthalb jahren geschlossenes
positionspapier wird konkreten impulsen
dass sie die strategien gemäß ihrem
vorhaben dann noch bis zum ende der 20
legislaturperiode umsetzen wollen ist
hoffentlich wieder ein hinweis auf
fehlende quantität noch qualität sie
nehmen sich viel zeit zur planung zeit
die am ende für die umsetzung fehlt und
zeit die die betroffenen nicht haben
denn unsere mitmenschen sind bereut
bereits heute einsam und genau zu sein
jetzt in diesem moment mehrere millionen
betroffene sind unfreiwillig teil
sozialer isolation und neben unseren
seniorinnen und senioren sind es auf
junge alleinstehende und menschen mit
behinderung die aus verschiedensten
gründen auf soziale teilhabe verzichten
müssen und nach einer mehrjährigen
pandemie sind es nun die steigenden
preise die massive folgen haben werden
denn zukünftig entscheiden sich mit
blick auf die explodierenden gas und
strompreise noch mehr menschen gegen
café besucher mit freunden gegen
ausflüge mit der familie gegen das
eintrittsgeld fürs kino gegen den
kostenpflichtigen vereinssport oder
gegen andere gesellschaftliche
veranstaltungen sie werden sich für eine
warme wohnung und für heißes wasser
entscheiden müssen und da helfen
einmalig 300 euro auch nicht wirklich
weiter
armut stellt nach wie vor ein
bedeutendes risiko für einsamkeit da und
ein bekanntes und nun von von uns auch
gern gefördertes erfolgsmodell gegen
einsamkeit in jeder altersstruktur sind
die mehrgenerationenhäuser den sie aber
nach dem ende des corona auf paketes
auch die mittel kürzen ich bitte sie
also sehr sehr geehrte bundes senioren
ministerin setzen sie keine falschen
signale und nehmen sie diese hinweise in
den anstehenden beratungen mit auf
vielen dank
allianzen hat hier noch einmal auf die
situation der rentnerinnen und rentner
verwiesen auch das war ja in den
diskussionen zum entlastungspaket thema
in den letzten tagen und wochen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin wehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger ich möchte mit
etwas grundsätzlichen beginnen frau
ministerin paus sind ende april in das
amt gekommen und mehr oder weniger
direkt in die haushaltsverhandlungen
gestartet verhandlungen von dem wir uns
alle gewünscht hätten dass die unter
anderen bedingungen stattfinden mit
blick auf die ausverhandelten zwei
milliarden euro jährlich für das kita
qualitäts gesetz möchte ich ihnen meinen
respekt aussprechen
mit blick auf die gesamtsituation war
das alles andere als einfach ist sehr
wichtig dass wir für diese nachfolge des
gute kita gesetzes im haushalt die
finanzielle förderung konstant halten
werden und dass sie es geschafft haben
einen besseren ausgleich zwischen detail
habe viele eltern und der
qualitätsentwicklung zu erreichen ich
möchte kurz sagen was das für die kinder
meinem bundesland bedeutet wir können
einen gesetzlichen mindestlohn ahl
schüssel endlich einführen und wir
können die verbesserung der
fachkräftesituation durch eine
verbesserung der duale orientierten
ausbildung auf den weg bringen das ist
gut aber
jetzt jetzt wir als parlament gefragt
wir alle kennen das bundesprogramm
sprach kitas sollte schon drauf thema
wir alle kennen den leitspruch des
programms weil sprache der schlüssel zur
welt ist
wir alle wissen wie wichtig die arbeiten
hin sprach geht das ist sie sind gelebte
praxis für mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit
und genau deswegen bescheinigen uns die
fachkräfte und die wissenschaft dass
unser spar kinderprogramm das
erfolgreichste programm des bundes in
den vergangenen jahren sind durch die
sprache das bundesweit strukturen
entstanden die sprachliche bildung
fördern und damit gerade den menschen
helfen die es nicht so einfach haben
über 500.000 kinder und deren familien
profitieren direkt von den sprachtest
jede achte kitas eine sprache da jede
nacht kita
wir wollen die erfahrung aus den sprache
das für alle anderen kitas nutzen um in
allen einrichtungen als bund diese
entscheidende sprach bildung der kinder
zu unterstützen
es ist eine richtige entscheidung die
staatliche bildung im neuen kita
qualitäts gesetz zu stärken
aber wenn die mehr sparen wollen dann
brauchen wir natürlich auch mehr
finanzielle unterstützung des bundes für
uns als spd schon lange klar dass der
bund mehr verantwortung der
frühkindlichen bildung übernehmen muss
denn nur der bund kann helfen
bildungsgerechtigkeit im ganzen land zu
gewährleisten
es darf sich egal sein ob die qualität
der frühkindlichen bildung eines kindes
davon abhängt ob sie in stuttgart
pirmasens hagen oder in neubrandenburg
sprach geht das sind durch die
bundesförderung auch deshalb die gelebte
praxis des sprechens nach gleichwertigen
lebenswertesten deshalb haben wir eine
verantwortung für die strukturen der
sprach kitas und dieser verantwortung
müssen wir gerecht werden und klarheit
schaffen projekten hat darauf
hingewiesen wir müssen jetzt als bund
und länder
gemeinsam die beschäftigten und eltern
in den sprach- kitas ein schnelles
signal geben dass ohne unterbrechungen
2023 weitergeht ich bin deshalb stolz
dass sich die spd bundestagsfraktion in
der anstrengenden haushaltsverhandlungen
dafür einsetzen wird dass die sprach
kitas eine zukunft im rahmen des kita
qualitäts gesetz haben und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir in den nächsten
wochen auch in der koalition zu einem
guten ergebnis im sinne im sinne unserer
kinder und ihrer sprachlichen bildung
kommen werden
ich möchte mich zum schluss meiner rede
bei den vielen erzieherin eltern und
großeltern bedanken die sich für eine
halt der sprach kitas einsetzen sie
sammeln unterschriften gehen auf uns
abgeordnete zu machen sich laut und
konstruktiv starkwinden halbjahr
sprachliche bildung unserer kleinsten
sie sind für mich vorbilder in einer
welt die aktuell zum verzeichnis scheint
lassen sie uns für diese menschen jetzt
anpacken danke
treib edelhäuser hat jetzt das wort für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle wissen
dass die zeiten in dem wir gerade leben
herausfordernd sind die auswirkungen von
corona die auf uns zurollen der
energiekrise die ukraine krieg die
machen das regieren nicht unbedingt
einfach und angenehm und sofern möchte
ich natürlich auch sein als bankkaufmann
und bbl ist mir natürlich bewusst dass
es nicht einfach ist in diesen zeiten
einen stabilen und soliden haushalt zu
präsentieren auf die beine zu stellen
das geld das man irgendwie ausgibt muss
auch irgendwo herkommen das muss auch
irgendwo erwirtschaftet werden doch die
menschen in diesem land die verlassen
sich auf sie und sie erwarten natürlich
auch dass alles dafür getan wird dass
wir durch diese krisen auch sicher
geführt werden und da habe ich
mittlerweile landauf landab bei den
gesprächen so die zweifel dass die ampel
das auch schafft dass ihnen das auch
gelingen wird mehr fortschritt wagen
dass das logo des koalitionsvertrages
und sie wollten zeigen dass sie nach 16
jahren unionsgeführte regierung ja nun
alles besser machen ich würde sagen das
sehe ich nicht dieses vorhaben würde ich
noch als in frage stellen besonders im
bereich familie senioren frauen und
jugend waren die erwartungen an die
regierung sehr sehr hoch ihre
vollmundigen versprechen dass die
familien gestärkt werden dass die kinder
und jugendlichen in den fokus gerückt
werden dass das ehrenamt einen wert
ihren platz finden wird das schneller
geplant wird ja die platzen irgendwie
schneller als die seifenblasen von
meinen vierjährigen sohn er so bei
themen wie abschaffung § 19a oder
legalisierung von cannabis da sind sie
richtig enthusiastisch unterwegs und
zeigen auch entscheidungswillen auch
hier im plenum aber was ist mit der
enttäuschten fachkraft die in der kita
ihre sprach kita aus wird da steht auf
seite 5 und 17 ihrem koalitionsvertrag
das programm der sprach kitas muss
weiter entwickelt werden das muss
verstetigt werden und nun nun muss diese
fachkraft feststellen dass ihre dienste
ab nächstes jahr einfach nicht mehr
gebraucht werden weil der bund ist nicht
mehr finanziert und so geht es nicht nur
hier so so wie es auch sieben halb
tausend anderen damen und herrn
kolleginnen und kollegen die hier in
diesen betätigungsfeld einfach tätig
sind ja damit verliere strukturen die
aufgebaut worden sind und verlieren das
entsprechende know how und das in der
zeit in einer zeit in der mit corona
noch ein großer bedarf da ist in der
sprachentwicklung einer zeit in der wir
die ukraine krieg weiter menschen und
kinder mit migrationshintergrund zu uns
in unser land kommen und unsere sprache
kitas einfach nötig ketten und unsere
kindergärten einfach nutzen möchten oder
schauen wir auf die jungen menschen die
im nächsten jahr ein freiwilliges jahr
einlegen wollen in freiwilligendiensten
da hat der bundespräsident ja erst noch
gesagt wir wollen ein soziales
pflichtjahr anregen da die hoffnung auf
aussagen plätze wer durch das nötige
konsequente entscheidung aber was haben
wir haben etwa 300.000 nachfrage und nur
100.000 plätze ja da kann eine glück
haben wenn eine stelle bekommt leider
wird es also versäumt das mich auch
diesen etat entsprechend etwas erhöht um
den bedarf auch gerecht zu werden oder
wie schaut's aus bei den trainern und
übungsleitern in den vereinen in den
sportvereinen die ehrenamtlich tätigen
die jugendliche trainieren die in einem
koalitionsvertrag gesehen haben da steht
ein entwicklungsplan sport drin der
erarbeitet werden soll das sollte doch
ein blick durch die deutschen
sportlandschaft gehen und was war ja
nichts ist es wird stattdessen die
sportstättenförderung eingestellt wird
gestrichen ja nichts ist mit der
renovierung der in die jahre gekommenen
schon und sporthallen es sind viele
themen die hier angesprochen werden und
ich glaube dass wir das ehrenamt und das
auf das kommt uns alle an und ich glaube
das sind wir alle der gleichen meinung
hier dass wir hier einfach mehr tun
müssen unser ehrenamt ist das ist der
kitt unserer gesellschaft und sie
ehrenamtlich in vereinen verbänden tätig
und es ist nicht nur die betreuung der
kinder am nachmittag oder am wochenende
ist es viel viel mehr und deswegen
glaube es ist falsch hier irgendwo
weniger zu tun als man eigentlich
müssten und deswegen glaube ich dass
endlich ist an der zeit ist dass wir die
bedürfnisse für unsere kinder wieder in
den fokus rücken das war einfach
wirklich mehr fortschritt markt und
deswegen glaube ich der regierung aus
bündnisgrünen der spd und die fdp mit
auf den weg zu geben dass das vertrauen
dass das land in sich setzt dass dieses
vertrauen in die menschen einfach ja
zunehmend verlieren ich würde nicht
wundern wenn es bei der nächsten wahl
einfach nicht so gut mehr für sie
ausschaut das kann allerdings der spur
vielleicht folgt lauten lieber doch von
der union regiert als am ende des tages
schlecht regiert hier kann es recht sein
vielen herzlichen dank
im bundestag gibt es auch eine
kinderkommission die sich um die belange
der kinder kümmert und die vorsitzende
dieser kommission die wird nun als
nächste sprechen sarah lag am spd
fraktion
in aller ruhe das zählt für mich auf die
zeit
es muss ja passen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen unsere welt von
heute ist bunt so bunt und vielschichtig
wie familien aber egal wie sie aussehen
würden sie haben eins gemeinsam sie alle
sorgen sich angesichts der aktuellen
globalen krisen und der steigenden
inflation es brennt für familien an
allen ecken und enden die hat sich meine
wohnung die bezahle ich den
wocheneinkauf die klassenfahrt oder die
tage verlangen dass einige ihrer fragen
familien sind wichtige pfeiler unserer
gesellschaft daher lassen wir
sozialdemokratinnen sie nicht alleine
und noch weniger länger worten das thema
kinder abend beschäftigt uns nicht erst
seit gestern wir alle wissen dass in
deutschland die chancen von kindern und
jugendlichen immer noch vom geldbeutel
der eltern abhängen deshalb wollen wir
eine kindergrundsicherung einführung um
kinder noch stärker aus der armut zu
holen aber bis dahin bis zur einführung
dürfen wir nicht untätig sein viele
entlastungen haben wir glücklicherweise
bereits auf den weg gebracht so zb in 22
den kinderbonus als einmalzahlung die
kinder sofort zuschlag oder auch die
anhebung des mindestlohns auf 12 eur
welcher gerade für familien mit kleinen
einkommen schröder entlastend wirkt
aufgrund der dynamik der inflation
müssen wir allerdings noch mehr tun
gerade auch die sgb 2 empfängerin
brauchen verstärkt unsere hilfe und
diese werden sie auch bekommen zum
beispiel durch die einführung des
bürgergeldes anfang nächsten jahres aber
auch für familien mit kleinen einkommen
wird es gegenwärtig immer schwerer ihre
rechnung am ende des monats zu zahlen
deshalb hat die ampel regierung am
wochenende ihren entwurf für ein drittes
noch größeres entlastungs paket
vorgelegt
um die zeit bis zur einführung der
kindergrundsicherung zu überbrücken
wollen wir unter anderem das kindergeld
um 18 euro erhöhen und den höchstbetrag
des kinderzuschlags auf 250 euro anheben
mit einer reform des wohngeldes
inklusive einführung des
heizkostenzuschusses
wollen wir zudem deutlich mehr menschen
erreichen und so auch familien durch
diese schwierige zeit helfen
entlastungen sind daher auch für
familien das stichwort überhaupt doch es
reicht nicht sie nur finanziell zu
entlasten familien müssen gerade in
zeiten der krise insgesamt gestärkt
werden
so braucht eltern mehr zeit für ihre
kinder sie müssen die gelegenheit haben
sich die sorge arbeit gleichberechtigt
untereinander aufzuteilen und das von
anfang an für mich persönlich eine
herzensangelegenheit in dieser
legislaturperiode
im koalitionsvertrag haben wir deshalb
das sogenannte partnerschafts paket
bereits angekündigt und mittlerweile
auch ins rollen gebracht hier gibt es
immer einen guten start ins leben
konkret um eine zweiwöchige freistellung
des vaters beziehungsweise des zweiten
elternteils nach der geburt eines kindes
eltern sollen als familie ankommen
können und der vater oder der zweite
elternteil soll die möglichkeit bekommen
sich bei der pflege und der betreuung
des babys von anfang an aktiv mit
einzubringen ich selbst kann das als
vierfache mutter nur begrüßen und freue
mich schon sehr auf die jetzt
anstehenden verhandlungen
elterngeld ein voller erfolg der stehen
für eine erweiterung der partnermonate
an fakt ist wir brauchen bedarfsgerechte
instrumente für familien damit eltern
auch in zeiten der krise mehr zeit für
ihre kinder finden haben wir starke
familien so haben wir auch starke kinder
kinder sind unsere zukunft und sie
können unsere gesellschaft zum besseren
gestalten in zeiten der klimakrise und
transformationen eine wichtige aufgabe
dafür müssen wir sie besonders
vorbereiten und ihnen und ihren familien
ein gutes leben ermöglichen vielen dank
soweit sarah kam wie gesagt vorsitzende
der kinderkommission und mitglied in der
kinderkommission ist auch paul lehrieder
für die cdu csu fraktion
denn denn liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen als haushälter und
fachpolitiker für den bereich familie
ist man in anbetracht der
haushaltsberatungen die er diese woche
beginnen und gerade bei diesem
einzelplan immer einen besonderen
zwiespalt unzählige maßnahme aus den
unterschiedlichsten lebensbereichen der
menschen viele davon gut und wichtig
müssen dennoch kritisch bewertet und
anschließend solide finanziert
abgebildet werden diesen spagat muss
sich jeder zutrauen der gute politik für
familien frauen jugendliche und senioren
machen wenden daran muss sich die ampel
messen lassen daran messen sie die
menschen in unserem land aber da ist
noch luft nach oben dies gilt
insbesondere nutze dabei bewusst die
terminologie der ampel im hinblick auf
die viel beschworenen zeitenwende
glaube auch dass wir momentan in
besonders herausfordernde zeiten leben
aber dann sind wir doch umso mehr
aufgefordert kritisch zu bewerten zu
hinterfragen zu priorisieren und
schwerpunkte zu setzen für unsere
familien für unsere frauen für die
kinder für die jugendlichen für unsere
senioren dafür setzen sich die cdu/csu
gerade auch in diesen schwierigen zeiten
ein der hier zur diskussion vorliegende
entwurf des einzelplan 17 sieht für das
kommende jahr ausgaben von 12,9
milliarden vor schauen wir weiter in die
finanzplanung bis zum jahr 2026 dann
wird diese haushalt um weitere 1 5
milliarden euro anwachsen berücksichtigt
man dabei dass das ministerium von den
zahlreichen ankündigungen im
koalitionsvertrag
bislang nur noch sehr wenige umgesetzt
hat dann gehen diese 1,5 milliarden auf
eine sehr zurückhaltende kalkulation
zurück sie werden also doch noch
deutlich mehr geld ausgeben im hinblick
dass die grundsicherung noch gar nicht
eingerechnet im hinblick auf eine solide
finanzpolitik und das einhalten der
schuldenbremse findet hier leider
wirklich eine zeitenwende aber bleiben
wir zunächst beim haushalt für das
kommende jahr aufgrund gesetzlicher und
vertragliche leistung stehen von diesen
veranschlagten 2,9 milliarden euro
bereits 90 prozent nicht ohne weiteres
zur disposition also das sind in der
entscheidungsbefugnis des parlaments
aufgrund gesetzlicher verpflichtungen
längst entzogen
der größte posten stellt dabei mit 8,3
milliarden euro das elterngeld das vor
allem aufgrund der positiven entwicklung
der nettolöhne aus der regierungszeit
der union bedarfsgerecht angehoben
werden muss so weit so gut etwas
schwieriger gestaltet sich entgegen bei
den zusätzlich bewilligten mitteln der
bundesstiftung mutter und kind schutz
des ungeborenen lebens die sie im
zurückliegenden parlamentarischen
verfahren bewilligt haben und die zur
unterstützung von flüchtlingen aus der
ukraine im jahr 2023 nun nicht mehr
fortgeschrieben werden denken sie
ernsthaft dass eine rückkehr der
geflüchteten menschen in die ukraine
noch in diesem jahr realistisch ist den
mit abstand größten pop die kollegin pia
und egl hause haben bereits darauf
hingewiesen haben sie allerdings mit der
nicht vorführung des bundesprogramms
sprach niedergeschossen zu dem sie sich
bis zu den haushaltsberatungen noch
vollmundig bekannt haben und ich glaube
kollegen jensen von der fdp auch
geschrieben hat wir schreiben jetzt die
50 prozent ins gesetz in das kita
qualitäts gesetz das tatsächlich eben
hier eine vernünftige abschichtung der
problematik angezeigt ist ich glaube
alle wie wir hier sitzen sind der
auffassung dass frühkindliche
sprachförderung wichtig ist und auch
fortgeführt werden sollen wir statt uns
nur dessen aufgabe es ist wir haben vor
elf jahren zwölf jahren das
bundesprogramm auf den weg gebracht als
initiative zusammen was hier möglich ist
jetzt sagt natürlich die koalition
wir wollen diese aufgabe wieder stärke
den ländern zu weit oder komplett in
länder zu weisen und die länder werden
natürlich unterschiedlich darauf
reagieren fakt ist wir haben ein gutes
kita gesetz in dem steht keine quoten
drin die tatsächlich für die
qualitätssiegel kita aufgebracht werden
müssen fakt ist es gibt
ministerpräsidenten ich denke eine
ministerpräsidentin nordosten unseres
landes die cds größte den größten teil
des geldes aus dem google kita-gesetz in
die beitragsfreiheit gegeben haben
werden diese ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidentin in den ländern
tatsächlich zum ersten januar 2023 die
beitragsfreiheit zurückfahren und sagen
jawohl dafür machen wir sprach kitas
sind sie wirklich ebenso utopische
illusorisch zu glauben dass diese
aufnahmen ich bin der auffassung aber
haben wir das immer ziemlich nah
beieinander dass wir eine langgezogene
kurve brauchen wir müssen die länder ins
boot holen wenn heute das kultida
qualitäts gesetz beschlossen wird es
kann das nach dem haus hat beschlossen
hätten dann dauert es noch etwa ein jahr
zeit bis die verantwortung über die
verwaltungsvereinbarung mit den ländern
geschlossen sind die gelder können als
ausgezahlt werden wenn alle
verwaltungsvereinbarungen in
trockenen tüchern sind das heißt wir
können nicht damit rechnen dass am
ersten januar gelder für das kita
qualitäts gesetz für die vielen
sprachförderung in den ländern zur
verfügung stellen egal wie der
bürgermeister wie die kita st wir lassen
die momentan laufenden verträge am 31.12
2022 auslaufen und wissen nicht wie es
am ersten ersten 23 weiter gehen und
dabei
dagegen mal anziehen lassen wir darüber
reden sönke rix hat er als alter
fahrensmann den weg geben auf gemacht
also einfach mal darüber reden wie man
da diese brücke bilden können bis man
die länder ins boot holen und ich sehe
in der mitte kann wo denn frank bsirske
lieber frank bsirske die kinder die wir
heute nicht verändern werden durch
sprachdefizite im kita-bereich im
grundschulbereich mit den schulischen
bereich in der ausbildung in 15 jahren
schwierigkeiten haben wir diskutieren
mit engel mit krokodilstränen über die
problematik fachkräftesicherung und
gleichzeitig erlauben wir uns eben
potenziale die wir bei uns bei den
kindern haben ein stückweit brachliegen
zu lassen
wir sind
dass wir die langgezogene kurven um ihr
erster und ihr die länder mit ins boot
zu holen nicht dass sie nicht kriegen
und ich
will die uhren ab gewesen
paul lehrieder war das und natürlich ist
es ein großes thema soll er die qualität
der kita ausgebaut werden oder die
beitragsfreiheit gesichert werden
jasmina hostert spricht jetzt für die
spd
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich mache mir große sorgen das waren die
worte einer alleinerziehenden mit der
ich kürzlich in meinem wahlkreis
böblingen gesprochen habe das eine kind
kommt nun in die grundschule hefte
stifte schulranzen müssen besorgt werden
die hohen ausgaben für schulmaterialien
die gestiegenen lebensmittelpreise und
die nun explodierenden energiekosten bei
gleichbleibendem gehalt bei mir kommt
gerade alles zusammen sagte die mutter
zu mir
von den preissteigerungen sind
alleinerziehende und familien mit
kindern besonders stark betroffen je
mehr kinder in einer familie aufwachsen
umso stärker schlagen sich die
preiserhöhungen durch ich möchte nicht
dass familien und alleinerziehende in
existenznöte kommen ich möchte dass
ihren kindern ein schönes schulstart
ermöglichen und zuversichtlich in die
zukunft blicken können und deshalb ist
für meine fraktion klar wir sorgen für
schnelle und unmittelbare unterstützung
wir haben familien und alleinerziehende
im blick und lassen sie nicht alleine
mit den ersten zwei und leistungspaketen
haben wir zum beispiel den kinderbonus
von 100 euro pro kind und den sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro im monat auf den
weg gebracht im dritten paket erhören
wir nun den kinderzuschlag für familien
mit niedrigem einkommen auf 250 euro im
monat und dann steigern wir auch noch
das kindergeld um monatlich 18 euro um
einfach nur mal zwei beispiele aus dem
neuen entlastungspaket zu nennen
für uns ist aber auch klar dass wir die
situation von familien und
alleinerziehenden nachhaltig verbessern
müssen denn die realität ist bereits vor
der krise kamen sie an ihre grenzen und
deshalb schaffen wir bessere
rahmenbedingungen wie zb durch gute
bildungs und betreuungsangebote und
was das kita qualität gesetz betrifft
ist ja die union sehr pessimistisch und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir
optimistisch sind in wir werden es
anpacken und wir werden das auch auf den
weg bringen
warum ist die betreuung für uns so
wichtig die betreuung ist deshalb so
wichtig denn wenn eltern einmal aus der
sicht der eltern wenn die kinder gut
aufgehoben sind können nämlich eltern
guten gewissens ihrer arbeit nachgehen
und vor allem schaffen wir dadurch gute
voraussetzungen und gute
lebensperspektiven für alle kinder
unabhängig vom einkommen oder vom
familienstand der eltern und das packen
wir eben kräftig an mit unserem kita
qualitäts gesetz und dem ausbau der
ganztagsbetreuung an grundschulen
auch hier sind wir sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir das gut auf den weg bringen
werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mehr als
80 prozent der alleinerziehenden sind
frauen
und es sind frauen die häufig noch immer
von bestehenden ungerechtigkeiten im
erwerbsleben betreffenden betroffen sind
deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
nach einer trennung frauen erst gar
nicht in die finanzielle not geraten
dazu gehört zum beispiel dass wir mütter
aus der teilzeit falle holen dazu gehört
aber auch dass väter sich stärker in die
betreuung der kinder einbinden aber auch
dass frauen für die gleiche arbeit
genauso viel verdienen wie männer
hinzu kommt es sind vor allem frauen die
aktuell weniger als zwölf euro in der
stunde verdienen und das ändern wir ab
dem ersten oktober mit der erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro und das ist
wunderbar und auf diesen schritt sind
wir sozialdemokratinnen sozialdemokraten
sehr stolz
ich mache mir große sorgen dass in
aktuell die worte vieler familien und
alleinerziehende
für uns ist aber klar wir lassen euch in
dieser krise nicht alleine und auch
nicht danach mit diesem haushalt stellen
wir sicher dass schnelle und nachhaltige
unterstützung zur verfügung gestellt
werden auch gut hilfen sind sehr wichtig
aber genauso wichtig ist es kulturen zu
schaffen die familien allein im linken
hat sich stärken die koalition liefert
und packt beide banken
soweit jasmina hosted und wir bleiben
beide spd fraktionen der letzte redner
in dieser debatte zum einzelplan 17 ist
felix büring
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
deutschland ist eine wehrhafte
demokratie und die überwältigende
mehrheit in diesem haus findet das auch
gut
wehrhafte demokratie bedeutet einerseits
dass wir effektiv und mit der gebotenen
härte gegen all jene vorgehen die unsere
demokratie angreifen und die versuchen
sie abzuschaffen
wehrhafte demokratie bedeutet aber
andererseits eben auch dass wir die
verantwortung haben zu investieren in
die zukunft unserer demokratischen
gesellschaft und dazu trägt dieser
einzelplan 17 über den wir heute
sprechen enorm zu bei lassen sie mich
gerne auch erklären warum nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg hat man die
historische lehre gezogen wir wollen
keine große starts jugend mehr wir
wollen eine vielfalt unabhängiger
demokratisch organisierte jugendverbände
die als eigenständige mitglieder
organisation einen enorm wichtigen
beitrag zu unserer demokratie leisten
und im übrigen gilt wer sich in der
jugendverbandsarbeit engagiert hat bei
dem ist die wahrscheinlichkeit um so
höher dass er oder sie sich auch später
ehrenamtlich engagiert und deswegen sage
ich deswegen sagen wir jeder cent jeder
euro für die jugendverbandsarbeit ist
eine investition in die gegenwart und in
die zukunft unserer demokratie eine
investition mit enorm hoher die
kroatischer rendite meine damen und
herren
junge menschen die ein theaterstück
entwickeln und aufführen in dem es darum
geht warum es eben keine unterschiede
zwischen menschen unterschiedlicher
herkunft gibt die unterstützung von
menschen die von rechter gewalt
betroffen sind und auch die förderung
der medienkompetenz die gerade in
unserer heutigen zeit in der wir leider
erleben müssen dass insbesondere
diejenigen die unsere demokratie von
rechts angreifen systematisch versuchen
den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk zu
delegitimieren und die ganz bewusst
versuchen die algorithmen sozialer
netzwerke zu nutzen um ihren hass und
ihre falsch nachrichten zu verbreiten
gerade in diesen zeiten hat
medienkompetenz einen so enorm hohen
stellenwert und auch denen fördern wir
über den haushaltsposten demokratie
fördern
wie wichtig uns all diese dinge sind das
zeigen die nackten zahlen
2015 hatten wir im bereich demokratie
förderung 40 millionen drin
2022 waren es schon
183 millionen jetzt sind es 200
millionen das bedeutet dass innerhalb
der letzten acht jahre eine
vervierfachung nein eine verfünffachung
sogar der mittel stattgefunden hat und
mit dem demokratie fördergesetz dass wir
bald auf den weg bringen werden werden
wir auch eine gesetzliche regelung für
die verstetigung dieser mittel einführen
und das bedeutet noch mal dass wir ganz
klar sehen können welchen stellenwert
die demokratie förderung für diese ampel
koalition hat meine damen und herren
kolleginnen und kollegen aufgabe des
staats ist es zivilgesellschaft zu
fördern eine demokratische gesellschaft
kann nicht von oben verordnet werden
aber aber gut zu hören jetzt aber wir
können die füße stärken auf denen sie
steht staat und zivilgesellschaft
zusammen stark herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
soweit die debatte zum einzelplan 17
familie senioren frauen und jugend das
ist natürlich nicht die abschließende
aussprache sondern da werden die
abgeordneten noch drüber diskutieren und
sie sehen ist hier gibt es nun ein
bisschen
stühlerücken die familienpolitischen
sprecher verlassen jetzt den plenarsaal
und die wohnungsbau politischen spricht